what is that
sage this whole freaking compound must
be infused with it and yet i can't find
sage anywhere and i've looked maybe it's
not sage we're smelling maybe it's money
it's the netflix limited series everyone
is talking about inventing anna joining
us now is anders holm who plays jack
hello hey what's up congratulations on
this limited series i mean to say
everyone is talking about it i feel like
is an understatement it is trending
people are engaged on social media all
about it how does how does it feel it
feels good you know it's a crazy story
and uh we were a little worried that
through the pandemic people might forget
about it but uh it's the kind of
escapist story that everyone's like oh
yeah let's get into this what made you
drawn to this project when you first
read the script were you immediately
like i have to be a part of this
well i said uh i want a one-way trip to
shondaland
you know not a bad place to uh want to
be shonda makes hits and with her at the
reins of this incredible story you knew
it was gonna be awesome you knew it
would be done right as well exactly
she's got a flare and by the way even
when you read the script the stuff that
you guys never get to see
in the action
it's fun to read it's not just like the
door opens it's like
it's it's she's great that's awesome now
how are you guys all
celebrating the success of this series i
know you are kind of taking celebration
to a whole other level and we have a
little photo that we're going to bring
up here okay
right there yeah
so there's a story behind that okay
what's the story uh we didn't have a
premiere just uh coveted people
everywhere big cast so they sent us
these step and repeats
to our homes but i was in mexico filming
a movie
so they sent it to my hotel and i didn't
have a suit
the only suit that i had
was a speedo because i was hitting the
pool trying to do uh you got to be
creative show people my cool nipples
well you know clothes usually fall off
in mexico anyway this is true this is
true
now moving on we'll remove that and
we'll put a more wholesome photo up
there from uh there's nothing wrong with
that that's just a man's body like we
said if you got it plotted right but
while we talk about your tv wife we'll
put
her up there as well perfect now you two
have such great chemistry
on tv from a viewer's perspective how
did you guys work on that off camera
anna's the best i mean we're both like
chicago kids i grew up right outside the
city
um and we would talk about that and
she's just super nice she's the kind of
person you feel like you've known
for a long time she's just easy going
and then
when you're acting
you have to clock back in and go stop
watching her act act with her because
she's so good you just want to watch you
get to play the supportive husband which
is really art imitating life yeah yeah
i'm a husband at home
so i just bring that to her and i joke
with my wife that
she's very much like anna's character
on the show very
intense very dedicated to her work that
kind of thing so it's easy for you yeah
i'm in character i'm out of character
and character out of character how much
of your own role as a first-time dad
went into this because jack is preparing
to become a father i mean yeah i've been
through it three times now so it is
funny you do kind of go well actually we
did it this way and you can bring that
uh into the scene but also anna had all
these things and like she had to put on
the prosthetic
of like the belly bump for like three
months four months six months eight
months and
she really had dialed in the things uh
that correlated with the pregnancy did
she love it wearing that
oh yeah she loved it
no she hated it it's the worst it's like
this immovable object that's attached to
you and it's exhausting and getting in
and out of it
not easy i tried
the things that we do for our jobs right
it's wild it's wild by the way all i did
was wear pajamas for my job on the show
so uh you know i can't complain it's
literally like i mean that's been our
attire all pandemic anyways sweatpants
and pajamas so seamless this is really
just this is this is life for you
playing out in a limited series if
you've got a pajama company send me your
jammies
i'll rate them
i know what i'm talking about oh my
goodness what research did you do to
prepare for the role because i know
julia garner actually spoke with the
real anna did you speak to anybody no
but i met the real vivian and she was
like
my husband's happy that you're playing
he's a huge workaholics fan and i was
like cool uh he's a sculptor because
that's what my character was and she's
like no he's like an accountant but this
is way cooler
now what does the real vivian think of
this series because i know that the real
rachel
it has been critical of of how the
series is almost making anna star again
real anna has said that she won't watch
the show what does the real vivian think
i i honestly i don't know we should we
should get to the bottom of that but
guess what
anna delvey is a star that's why there's
a show about her she might be crazy but
there's something that's very watchable
about these stories of people who do
things that are
unbelievable that you just you don't see
all the time what do you think it is
between inventing anna and then also the
other netflix hit the documentary the
tinder swindler that people are so
hooked by
scams deceit
fame money cons all of it
i think it's it's it's kind of like
can people really do this it's almost
like fantasy but it's reality you don't
think that you could go through life
just kind of in anna delby's case like
bulldozing her way through we're all
polite for the most part and we we do
things by the rules and she just took
the rules
stepped on them kicked him out the curb
like she's doing her own thing and
in a weird way that's admirable if it's
used for good she used it for evil you
know and while she was doing all this as
a viewer as i watched it played out i
had so many questions right for you
being in it as an actor did you have
questions along the way too of how is
she getting away with this i mean it's
wild when she steals an airplane i mean
but the way that they play that out
you go yeah i guess if you just walk
like you've got this swagger you you
talk the talk
you can make this assistant who works at
the airplane company kind of go
i don't want to make my boss angry i
better just say okay
yeah and then you're screwed i mean
they're in the hospitality business they
want to make these people happy and then
people just take advantage of it and uh
get netflix shows about themselves by
the way now what's gonna happen are all
these people just gonna go out there and
be crazy and be like when's my show
coming out or they're just gonna go to
jail
and then there's no show
the reality is is this is like people
people do this yeah and think it's
and i've been getting i've been getting
texts from friends who are like
i love the show i had a boyfriend or a
girlfriend 10 years ago that basically
did this made me pay for a funeral for
their parents parents are still alive
and you're just like jaw to the floor
um so maybe it's more relatable than we
know which is but everyone's been kind
of like quiet and embarrassed to be like
i got hoodwinked too i think that's when
i asked you like what do you think it is
too of like why people are hooked so
much is because people like us were like
wait this actually really happens it
does right right and it's kind of
frightening i feel like i kind of hood
whacked my way into the show
i'm like a little bit of an anadelphi
no you're not you
you bring jack to life and you make jack
what it is and you're doing an
incredible job thank you we had fun what
would you say is the overall message
that the cast wants fans to know from
the show
um
that inventing anna's the best show
available right now i think the numbers
already proved that
i think that little spot in the trending
section already proves that good that's
good well congratulations on everything
and thank you so much for taking time to
come chat with us here at e3 we
appreciate it and in the meantime y'all
inventing anna is streaming now on that
place
[Music]